[Aplausos]
ah
buenas tardes inicialmente voy a hablar
de fotografía como una manera de
expresión como una forma de comunicación
como una aproximación a la frase que
dice una imagen dice oh vale más que mil
palabras
diariamente se suben cientos de imágenes
a internet y para las personas que
tenemos acceso esto constituye en una un
elemento fundamental de comunicación
estas plataformas nos brindan
posibilidades que antes eran imposibles
de pensar por ejemplo dos personas en el
lado opuesto del globo terráqueo que no
comparten idioma cultura y posiblemente
edad son capaces de empatizar por sus
preferencias visuales de conectar sin
hablar el mismo idioma de hacer clic
esto es posible porque el cerebro humano
asimila 4 veces más rápido las imágenes
que el texto y procesa 6 mil veces más
rápido las imágenes que el texto estamos
ante una posibilidad inmejorable de
comunicación sin embargo que estamos
diciendo estamos diciendo lo mismo a
través de imágenes que a través de texto
porque estudios vienen demostrando
lastimosamente hace décadas que la
cantidad de libros promedio que lee una
persona sean físicos o virtuales ha
descendido drásticamente en la última
década y dramáticamente los últimos años
cuando comencé en la fotografía
trabajaba en el centro de literatura de
una fundación cultural
y mientras avanzaba me di cuenta que la
literatura y la fotografía comparten
unidades simples de expresión en el
lenguaje escrito nosotros aprendemos que
tenemos oraciones simples y oraciones
compuestas en la fotografía pasa
exactamente lo mismo tenemos oraciones
simples cuyo contenido lo podríamos
describir utilizando pocas palabras y
oraciones compuestas cuyo contenido
tendríamos que describir empleando
muchas más palabras u oraciones
las fotografías simples en general
tratan de situaciones que son comunes a
todos nosotros una foto familiar una
foto de la mascota de una situación la
foto del face la foto de nuestro carnet
hay mucha diferencia no pero somos la
misma persona
para que se entienda un poco mejor esto
voy a mostrarles unas cuantas
fotografías para empezar él es mi hijo
ignacio
esta fotografía se podría sintetizar en
un renglón el niño está feliz
ignacio está sonrían porque es una
sensación común a todos nosotros
él es ignacio después de recibir el
sermón de papá por hacer caer su cámara
igual constituye una fotografía simple
la podemos resumir en una frase el niño
está triste ignacio está triste
las fotografías compuestas por otro lado
implican o pueden llegar a empatizar a
un grupo de personas por ende tienen que
incluir más información
para que podamos comprenderlas puede
enfatizar a un grupo de personas a un
grupo más grande de personas
a una ciudad
11 de enero para los coches amigos creo
que es suficiente
a un país nos gusta el carnaval
a una situación
esta es una cárcel en guatemala lo que
ven abajo de la imagen es un color ocre
que creo que no es necesario explicar
por qué
las fotografías compuestas en general
necesitan mucho más palabras para ser
explicadas en este sentido en fotografía
pasa algo que todos los fotógrafos
tenemos que considerar no seamos
fotógrafos o no para incluir más
palabritas dentro de nuestras imágenes
existe un equilibrio en lo que es la
composición que básicamente quiere decir
lo que vos decides incluir dentro de una
fotografía pero no solamente lo que está
adentro sino también lo que está afuera
lo que vos has escogido que quede fuera
una fotografía y que queda adentro de lo
que vos has escogido mostrar como una
síntesis de la situación y existe lo que
es el momento que atormenta mucho a los
fotógrafos que es exactamente cuándo
apretar el gatillo para disparar en ese
sentido nadie nos dice exactamente y nos
dice que es un instinto este equilibrio
entre composición y cuando disparar es
lo que atormenta a fotógrafos por años y
además lo que básicamente define la
manera en que un fotógrafo va a contar
algo o va a decir algo cualquier
fotógrafo o no no que decide entrar en
fotografía esto va a ser algo que va a
tener que desarrollar para poder incluir
dentro de sus imágenes más palabras en
este sentido hay dos consejos sumamente
básicos y económicos
que ayudan a desarrollar esta capacidad
el primero es dar la vuelta a la
fotografía la era digital nos permite
sacar una foto e instantáneamente sacar
otra y darle la vuelta o en un ordenador
crear una cop y darle la vuelta porque
es bueno dar la vuelta a la fotografía
porque la composición en fotografía se
define como el orden armónico de
elementos dentro de un encuadre que
hacen que una persona o el espectador
dirija su atención hacia determinado
punto
este orden o esta composición ayuda a la
fotografía si el mensaje se transmite de
una manera más clara
al dar la vuelta a la imagen nos ayuden
a componer porque todo lo que vemos
nosotros lo vemos en el interior del ojo
volteado eso quiere decir que si vemos
una fotografía en su posición original y
una fotografía en su posición volteada y
podemos identificar los elementos
principales de manera simple tenemos una
buena composición la explicación física
es sencilla como vemos en esta posición
y en el cerebro o en el ojo lo vemos en
esta posición en algún momento los
puntos más importantes van a generar un
doble estímulo en el cerebro por eso es
más fácil el siguiente consejo es cuando
sacamos la fotografía decidir cuándo
sacamos la fotografía se llama escoger
el 9 en momento preciso o como diría
henri cartier bresson el momento
decisivo de sacar la fotografía porque
si nosotros vemos en el encuadre una
foto y apretamos el botón en ese momento
ya ha pasado
tenemos que aprender a anticipar
entonces el mejor consejo es leer
quizás es un consejo bueno para toda la
humanidad por los índices de lectura
pero leer porque porque leer nos hace
imaginar si eres capaz de imaginar eres
capaz de observar y si eres capaz de
observar eres capaz de anticipar los
movimientos antes predecir lo que va a
pasar no puedes predecir que alguien va
a rodar las gradas pero puedes predecir
cómo va a caminar para sacar la
fotografía observando en este sentido un
consejo barato y simple es el siguiente
el tiempo en que tarda en hacerse
efectiva una fotografía no la velocidad
de obturación y el tiempo de disparo el
tiempo en que el comando tarda en
hacerse efectivo cuando apretamos el
botón es similar al tiempo en que tarda
a hacerse efectivo el control del vídeo
para hacer la pausa es exactamente igual
fuera que ver cine es una muy buena
sugerencia para los que quieran ser
fotografía o apreciar o incluir más
palabras en sus fotografías pasar tardes
viendo películas apretando el botón de
pausa
mejor a nuestro timing para sacar fotos
y dos nos ahorra preciosos disparos y
valiosos disparos de nuestras cámaras
fotográficas estos dos elementos
constituyen lo que es el equilibrio de
un fotógrafo la composición
el momento en que saco las fotografías
manejando esta ecuación se pueden
incluir más palabras dentro de una
fotografía o hacer que las fotografías
digan más
porque es importante esto
al principio les dije para los que
tenemos el uso y el acceso a internet es
una herramienta fundamental tener este
uso nos da un privilegio pero también
nos da una responsabilidad por lo que
para concluir esta charla les voy a
hablar un poco de fotografía en
mayúsculas
las fotografías compuestas
en general hablan de situaciones humanas
sociales mundiales injustas
la labor de fotoperiodistas
documentalista reporteros es fundamental
para que estas situaciones tengan
palabras tengan voz
toda la humanidad entra en la misma
fotografía si la tomamos desde la luna
toda la humanidad sin embargo un poco
menos de la humanidad tres mil millones
de personas no tienen acceso a internet
no tienen acceso a información no tienen
acceso a contar
colaboremos creando difundiendo mirando
incluyendo imágenes que contengan más
palabras nosotros tenemos la posibilidad
de hacer que la masividad y la difusión
generen los recursos necesarios para que
estas personas continúen haciendo su
trabajo colaboremos a que la historia
humana nuestra historia al menos en
difusión y quizás conciencia sea un poco
más justa muchas gracias
[Aplausos]